I wanted to introduce you to the newest
member of our crew say hello to our new
PA from The Bachelorette
Tyler see Tyler Cameron has a new gig as
david spade's production assistant well
sort of it's been a life changing has
been the most amazing thing I've ever
been a part of I'm super grateful for my
whole experience on Thursday's episode
of lights out with David Spade The
Bachelorette alum teamed up with a
comedian for a hilarious skit
oh hey liking the gig so far it's not
bad that pays good I've my own parking
spot and cysts gross and the staff have
already proposed to me maybe a little
unprofessional though I said no it all
seemed to be going fine for Tyler until
another PA showed up and ignited a
little competition all right here's the
thing we just looked at the budget we
only have enough money to keep one PA
and the staff we have another one so
Johnny will you come out here please
okay so who did David pick
the last eight hours you work here have
been obviously magical cherish the time
we spent together learning how the
copier works but Johnny is sort of
family Johnny the PA will you accept the
rose and if you thought they weren't
going to mention Hanabi you thought
wrong she's an amazing girl I think
there's there's you know I gave it my
all and she's she's incredible Tyler do
you know how to be yes John I do then
David did us all a solid ending the skit
with this epic request by the way I have
a request for you to take off your shirt
I feel so stupid that request was for
Johnny
okay so Tyler may not be working for
David but when et caught up with the
model recently he revealed there was one
job he turned down after his stint on
the hit ABC show I didn't want you to be
the bachelor was that ever offered to
you
yeah something we talked about but um
you know I just where I was at my life
and when I was in my life I just didn't
think it was where I wanted to be
[Music]